siccome ragazzi in questo blog non farò
i favi risponde per mancanza di tempo
vogliamo illustrarvi una delle realtà
della vita dalle quali sono stati
soggetti tutti almeno una volta come ti
aspetti realmente ributtarla
[Musica]
come invece lo fi nalmente
ragazzi questa è una delle cose più
senza senso che abbia mai registrato
cazzo è da tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono fa vj e non ci
siamo in un nuovo blog
prima di cui già ragazzi direi di
iniziare con la foto della settimana che
questa settimana è stata video da
valeria che ha fatto sto capolavoro
ragazzi che poi tra l'altro ho notato
milic il disegno cioè i capelli che sono
più ordinati di adesso ed è triste
ragazzi la prima news che vi voglio dire
oggi è importantissima
li avete ragazzi siccome siamo alla fine
di maggio e stanno finendo le scuole per
la nostra gioia io avendo la maturità
devo finire la scuola finisca fine
giugno più o meno proprio gli esami e
per questo motivo ragazzi in
quest'ultimo periodo a partire presente
da oggi mi devo mettere sotto fu lo
studio in una maniera che non ho mai
fatto così tanto tutta la mia vita credo
purtroppo ragazzi pubblicherò meno video
in questo mese perché fino alla fine di
giugno a capirli pubblico per carità
però ne pubblico di meno perché ciò
veramente pochissimo tempo a
disposizione per farli quindi se per
caso capita che diversi giorni non
faccio video sapete perché ma ragazzi
questa notizia ne segue una splendida
credo la migliore che potreste ricevere
forze spero subito dopo il periodo
d'esame quindi quando sarò libero da
queste catene che mi tengono legato dal
va bene avete capito mi prenderà almeno
un anno di tranquillità dallo studio
perché veramente ragazzi sono distrutto
perché veramente non ce la faccio più e
quest'anno ragazzi di tranquillità a
partire dalla fine di giugno mi
dedicherò ai video in un modo pazzesco
ragazzi mi chiama un salterò neanche un
cazzo di giorno perché ovviamente avendo
più tempo libero posso registrare di più
sarà splendido ragazzo uscito a fare un
cazzo di video al giorno e forse anche
qualcosa di più addirittura perché
ovviamente avendo il tempo libero posso
farlo grazie a dio e quindi ragazzi
spero di avervi dato una buona notizia
dopo gli esami sarà una cosa
spettacolare per tutti sono sicuro e
come seconda news ragazzi volevo dirvi
un'altra cosa abbastanza importante
ovvero ho aperto un profilo di wii chat
che l'applicazione tipo whatsapp ho
deciso di aprire un account siccome in
questi giorni a causa dello studio sarò
fuori casa in una maniera incredibile
non riuscirò a rispondere a un casino i
vostri messaggi lega perché sono fuori
casa pd ragazzi cerchiamo di rispondere
a tutti quelli che mi scriveranno anche
se sono fuori casa perché posso
rispondervi dal telefono fortunatamente
il nickname
per chi vuole iscrivermi e fa vj tv
questa foto qui questa foto strà sexy
tipo fini ragazzi per scrivermi basta
già chiami su wii chat praticamente sul
nejm fa vj tv e cercherò di rispondere
giuro alla maggior parte delle persone
che riesco spero a tutti quanti e grazie
a dio che ho trovato sto soluzione
perché essendo fuori casa non sapevo
come parlerò disperato quindi grazie
mille anche perché me l'ha suggerita
perché è stata una manna dal cielo
praticamente e siccome sono convinto la
vita al passato abbastanza i maroni con
le news come faccio sempre
direi di passare al fa vi risponde anno
cazzo non scatta gianora io non ci
faccio qui ragazzi sto mostrando ce ne
sta esaurendo maledizione cazzo ci siamo
anche stavolta tramite ok tac armi che
qualcuno di tutto ragazzi voglio
assolutamente aprire questo perché c'è
in italia non è così grande ma pesa un
quintale anche se non sembra tra l'altro
complimenti per la carta migliori 86
azzeccato in pieno ragazzi c'è una paura
[ __ ] di aprire sta roba ma vai con la
musichetta
[Musica]
che cazzo è per me la più lega che ciò
c'è un po di cose strane quad e allora
parte questo che a primo impatto mi
sembrava un dildo ma non fa niente
ragazzi ciò allora la per prima cosa una
fabi pezzi bellissima che che tra
l'altro è piena ma io sono un genio
scuotere ste cose magari potevo non
farlo voglio provare a fare una crociata
tanto sto gioco e finisce male però ci
provo cazzo
che cosa può saperlo sapevo lo sapevo lo
sapevo lo sapevo lo sapevo
un coso bellissimo del quale ignorò
l'utilità credo sia ma che cazzo sta
roba
ammettetelo ci sono sexy ragazzi così è
finalmente ragazzi l'ho ricevuto dopo
secoli
invece di ricevere sempre nutella ho
ricevuto una patata è la cosa dirmi mi
emoziona particolarmente tu che ti piace
la patata quindi telo inviata grazie
villa vico via hai capito tutto e come
tutti ragazzi un cartello vendesi che
non ho capito perché ma è bellissimo
grazie anche ragazzi non ho capito
perché non il cazzo di blog si sono
fatti sempre più enormi perché mi oddio
non ce la faccio più e come ultima
ragazzine gli passerà il terzo pacco che
mi sembra veramente figo dall'esterno
la cosa che mi piace stima che i ragazzi
che sono sfociati in modo facciamo
questo non esporci come che si usa per
le mani
quello che non esistente come la roccia
grazie mille per avranno pensato come
questo ci metterò 45 ore si si si sia
aperto sia per toccarmi abbiamo un
cappello il gran grazie 9 questo è
splendi passano molto sul web un cubo di
rubik che tra l'altro so anche fare ma
non pensi interessi e un cazzo di
nessuno comunque grazie mille e infine
ragazzi un aereo un aereoplanino
stupendo questo me l'attacco al
lampadario perché c'è il suo stile
l'ho fatto io ti piace fargli fare un
volo di prova grazie mille per la per il
post it a ragazzi 321 del giorno
[Musica]
ok cook e ragazze il video è piaciuto
come al solito sotto il commento mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook e
comuni video tratte nella descrizione si
sentì scrivete meno ci vediamo al
prossimo vino belle ragazze